leave square and believe it or not Wigan
have put down a star you can publish it
there with my name on it commemorating
my connection with the town which I'm
afraid ended in 1961 when we moved to
Bolton but I had my childhood here and
I've just been reminiscing and meeting
few friends who I didn't know before
who've come to say hello so let me huh
that's why I'm here well what are your
memories of wicked well I'm about to
write a book and you'll have to have to
read that of a lot of members of Bregan
a Wigan that was had struggled through
the war you know where there was no
television I remember seeing my first
television the shop window and Wigan the
boat race no internet of course but live
theatre very important for me at the
Hippodrome and the wicked little theatre
which is still there I used to act at
school both my primary school and then a
big in grammar school so it was all
really we gettin started me off on the
business of acting but I you know I
defined myself in all sorts of weather I
used to with me yeah absolutely i'm
alright I you know you could say I'm an
old man or I'm a gay man or an actor
like it says on the star but i do think
deep down in my heart I'm from Wigan and
I like the phrase I believe in Wigan
we're gonna believed in me I'm glad to
hear it and Wigan has no peer if your
God you want I say I was about to say
Wigan little figures no on the banks of
course and I remember going there myself
what memories do you have a wicked
little theatre well that's where I saw
my first Shakespeare Twelfth Night and
Macbeth I didn't act that but they used
to go and see a lot of place then that
was crucial and then the old
professional theatre and begin at the
Hippodrome theatres pull down now but
that was crucial to me and the variety
theatre s other
so I wish were going to had its own
professional theatre again perhaps it
will one day yeah let's fingers crossed
and how has it changed since you were
last there it's what 50 years ago since
you last in Wigan it's a very different
place now to then no I've been more
recently than that but I haven't had a
chance to walk around today perhaps I
will I think I think the sites are all
that men's Park of course we're going to
have a cup of tea now thing was opposite
where we lived in there and the cricket
club of course is still there at the
back of our house and the old grammar
school is the building is still there
and some of the arcades aren't they were
nice to spend my Saturday morning I had
threatens to spend three old pennies
Santa's office every time and then I
used to watch the I also watch that I
used to watch the guys on the market
stalls you know selling that stuff doing
their little routine those are the first
professional actors I saw they were
putting on a show and repeating
themselves over and over again that I
loved it it was easy to get easy to
entertain me when I was a kid I very
much remember Uncle Joe's mint balls and
pools pies is there still an integral
part of the town I believe when you go
back up there do you feel the warmth
from the people that Wigan azhar
welcoming you with open arms well of
course once you get north of Watford
everyone's friendly prepared with London
what she arrived in Lancashire of course
people are friendly you think of George
Formby he's the he should have his star
here I mean that they're ultra wigan lad
you know cheeky chappy man who invented
the joke about Wigan Pier and he sort of
sums up Wigan it was a bit gormless but
I think maybe that's gone has it now yes
William people aren't go missing
absolutely not a family furniture go for
that cup of tea because I know that make
you heading to Maine's part right in the
middle of Wigan for people who don't
know it very well when people say hello
to you today today remember you as a
Shakespearean actor or do they remember
you as Gandalf or does it not really
matter as long as they recognize you
well if they're my age they probably
seen me do some work in the theater if
they're as they often are teenagers or
or even younger then I know it's
probably lord of the rings that they've
enjoyed seeing but they don't make any
mistake they don't think I'm Gandalf
they think I'm gand elves representative
and decide when I used to go and see
father Christmas in the big big store
here at Christmas I knew that wasn't
father Christmas the real father
Christmas was getting ready for
Christmas he was somewhere else in far
too busy exactly we're gonna stop
exactly well I'm a bit like a bit like
that father Christmas we let you get on
and have a lot my mother to drop your to
you by the way strong with a bit of milk
put and put in last no sugar man after
my own heart you should thank you
preferably it's great to talk to you
thank you very much easy for joining us
on Sky use this afternoon thank you